this is
the ramsay show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsay show where dad is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice chris
hogan ramsey personality multiple number
one best-selling author
is my co-host today as we take your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five starting off this hour
is going to be anchorage
alaska cindy is with us hi cindy welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave hi chris thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so i had a question i'm currently in
baby step 3b
and i've been in alaska for on and off
for about nine years
working as a nurse um and i figured it's
time to
start looking to purchase either a condo
or a home
and i wanted to get your opinion um so
i'm currently i have where i could buy
a smaller one-bedroom condo but
kind of looking at the real estate
market it seems like those
condos have a longer resale like you're
on the market longer
so my question is is it better to go
ahead and
purchase like a smaller condo outright
or kind of wait a little bit longer and
either put a higher down payment on a
larger condo or a house or
obviously by 100 down but if that wasn't
the
ability so i just want to get your
opinion on that cool so you're you're
out of debt and you have your emergency
fund now you're saving your down payment
right
correct and i have enough that i could
buy like a small
like a one bedroom condo is like 105 to
115.
but um the resale on that what is your
income
yeah um anywhere depending on if i work
um
one or two jobs anywhere from 75 to 90
okay a year okay and so how long will it
take you to save up to buy
uh a little bit better than the one
bedrooms that don't set resell well
um i'm guessing probably about another
year
like to put a hundred percent down but i
could put
obviously that larger so you have a
hundred now
yes correct wow okay and how much longer
do you see yourself in alaska's
cindy well and that's kind of i have a
little gypsy stole so i've kind of been
i've got one foot in and one foot out
okay i i heard the southern come out
right there
in that gypsy soul originally oh we'll
see we might be related that's
us you're from the motherland kentucky
that's good
but i went to school in louisville so i
understand okay
but in your gypsy soul do you see
yourself there another three to five
years
or less
one half of me that's the and that's
where the caveat comes in one half of me
says yes because i didn't think i would
see myself here this long
okay i don't but at the same time don't
buy a one bedroom
yeah you told me three times uh that
they sell slow
and they don't appreciate well and so
it's just not a good investment
i mean you already knew that you didn't
need me to say it you were telling
yourself that
so the two options are you wait and save
unpay cash for
a little bit better property that you
could resell if you get ready to move
and you're not stuck in it and that also
means it's going to go up in value
because time on the market is also
correlated with appreciation most of the
time
meaning if something sells really fast
it's hot it usually is going up in value
and so that's the you know those two
things the days on the market are
correlated with appreciation rate in
your mls statistics typically
so i you know i'm okay if you buy today
and put half down and pay the other half
off in three years
gotcha okay or or if you want to wait
and pay a hundred percent
and you wait a year and a half or
whatever and you want to pay put 100
down either one's fine but i would not
buy the
soft market one bedroom now dave explain
the phrase
and this thing is said oftentimes in
real estate you make your money on the
buy
what does that mean well you you have to
buy something if you're gonna get a deal
at a deal
right and don't buy something that's got
a bad situation like those one bedrooms
in that market aren't
selling okay so that's you you you know
you made a poor decision at the buy
it's not necessarily the money that you
made but that's going to cost you money
on the sale
on the back end right and like the first
house uh i ever bought
was up on a hill uh and it wasn't up on
a good hill
it was like stuck inside of a bluff
and nasty and ugly i mean this house was
ugly ugly with a u
and i got a great deal on it but you
know what when i got ready to sell it it
was still ugly
and so i gave somebody a great deal how
long did it take for this thing to move
it took forever you know and so uh that
that's the problem you get into
is that you know if the reason you got a
good deal
is still there when you get ready to
sell you're gonna give somebody a good
deal
you know whether it's floor plan whether
it's the elevation from the street
whether it's the
fact that there's a flood of the one
bedrooms and there's they built too many
of them and a lot of the people
buying those necessarily aren't they're
not putting down routes
they're more transitory whatever yeah
whatever the reason is that you got a
deal going
in is the same reason you're going to
give a deal going out unless you can
change that and i mean if the reason you
got a deal was it was a foreclosure
it needed carpet paint and a roof curb
appeal
and and the curb appeal is fine but you
just need to cut down all the big bushes
and put down some new landscaping you
had
25 year old you know plants out front
that look like crap that kind of thing
and you go in and do a makeover on the
house now that you've changed the
equation there
that one makes sense but cindy i would
tell you this reach
out get an endorsed local provider
somebody that can give you that
objective third party opinion and guide
you
so you emotionally don't get so caught
up into it uh but
come up with a dollar range that you're
going to buy don't let the bank or
mortgage company
tell you how much you're gonna spend you
need to do that on your own yeah well
you've done such a great job she really
has
i mean you've saved up a hundred
thousand dollars
most people don't have a thousand
dollars that's exactly she's got a
hundred she's been intentional
she really has pretty impressive well
she's from kentucky dave she's she's
smart
i'm just gonna put that out there are
you yeah you're just gonna you think i'm
just gonna leave it later i think you
will
maybe not maybe not we can fight on air
it's okay for us to battle
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna laugh all the way into
the commercial break that's all i'm
gonna do
but seriously people out there i know
okay here you go
i know mortgage rates are low and
everyone's getting house fever and
you're getting tempted
but listen to me don't let interest
rates determine when you make this move
the goal is not to buy a home the goal
is to own that bad boy
outright so you stay in control of you
and your
thing what she's done she's done that
she really has she's sitting there on a
hundred thousand dollars
she easily could have been shopping with
a ninety thousand dollar household
income
for a three or four hundred thousand
dollar house easily yeah and instead
she's
questioning whether she ought to buy a
one hundred thousand dollar one bedroom
that means her heart's right her head's
right that's right and i don't care
where she's from she's acting smart she
is
smart
doesn't matter where she's from we're
gonna give her credit
oh well done well done yeah home
prices um people you know
getting the impulse fever this built up
thing inside of your spirit that is
forcing you and your emotional mind to
buy
the largest purchase you're gonna make
yeah this is a recipe for stupidity
it really is and this is how people get
burnt is doing this kind of stuff so
she's
she's being very very smart way to go
cindy great job
chris hogan ramsey personality and i
will be back right here on the ramsey
[Applause]
show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
so
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i am dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us open phones at
eight two five five two two five
luke is with us in green bay hi luke
welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you good afternoon dave and chris
sure question for you today
is regarding umbrella insurance my wife
and i a few years ago got a
one million dollar umbrella policy
liability
and just curious if there's a certain
net worth where we should look at
adding to it on to two and three and
four million as you go along or
is there a certain ratio that you can
say you kind of have a rule of thumb for
well it starts to get ridiculous when
you get above 5 million
the bargain is 1 million you a couple
hundred bucks you can buy 1 million
umbrella
but above 5 million you start to get
ridiculous um
i mean i have found a 10 million that's
decent i think i've got 10
right now but i also have the dave
ramsey problem i mean if i bump into
somebody they're gonna be going
oh i'm okay what's your name dave ramsey
oh god you know and so
all of a sudden you know it's like i got
a big target on my butt right so
um i went ahead and picked up an extra
level of it but i don't know that i
would necessarily recommend that
anything above five million
what i do tell you to do when you get
above the million
need i mean if you're starting to sit on
a net worth of um
uh you know north of three to five
million dollars and that kind of a thing
you're starting to worry million dollars
probably not enough
you really need to start looking at
other risk management things you can do
then and that's starting to put assets
into
uh llcs and trusts
and so forth i personally do not own a
single thing anymore
i don't even own my cars my cars are in
llc's
and that's all from a risk management
standpoint that the owner of the car is
the only person that could
only only entity that could get sued if
something happened the individual
only way i could get sued personally is
if i had committed a criminal act
and they could they could pierce it then
but but um
so like my one of my farms is in one llc
this building is in a trust uh and so on
i don't personally own anything and that
way if someone
falls over and one of those properties
or something happens around one of those
items
they can only if you lost the lawsuit
they could only take the assets in
that entity entity that's right and you
bring up the statement risk management
which is huge because you can work so
hard to build wealth
but if you don't protect it the right
way with an umbrella policy which all
that is folks is
it's another layer of coverage over your
automobile and your home owners
and so it's just like an umbrella that
you'd walk outside with it's that
extra layer of protection and dave said
it a million dollar policy is a couple
hundred dollars a year
yeah and so you can get that in place
but the llc and the trust they've
are crucial things for people to get set
up well and what you're gonna find is
is that when you get north of five
million dollars in net worth
if you're being wise and watching
everything there's two things to get
that start three things should start to
get very complicated your taxes
uh your risk management portfolio
meaning you start buying things in the
name of something else
and uh uh your estate plan
and the three of those things work
together uh you need to have the
entities built in such a way that they
serve the estate plan
but also serve risk management and so
that that's where you know you're going
to start to spend some money on defense
yes and on diligence to keep the
government's hands off to keep a target
off your butt that kind of stuff but
you know it's such a small dollar very
computer very few times
do i would i suggest it would be highly
unusual for me to suggest more than a 5
million
umbrella an umbrella only covers
liability too it doesn't cover anything
else so it's not it's not covering the
property itself you get
covered with traditional insurance yeah
but the umbrella it just attaches to the
liability limits on the top of your car
policy the top of your liability limits
on your car policy the top of the
liability limits on your homeowner's
policy
extends them out another million dollars
and at 250 bucks somewhere around there
and
all kinds of everyday millionaires out
there so if this is something that rings
true for you
i want you to go to daveramsey.com and
click on the insurance elp
and start to have that conversation like
this is the time to get those things in
place
yep sean is in bloomington indiana hey
sean welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
yeah so my wife and i are in a very
unique situation
on these past couple weeks she works for
an esop company
and they just recently got bought out by
another company so all the employees are
being paid out
in their vested shares wow
so my question is we have the option to
take out
a distribution up to 40 of the
payouts of the vested shares and my
question is do we take some of that
out to pay off all of our debt including
the house
and then roll over the rest in the 401k
option that they're providing with the
company
or um should we just roll everything
over into the 401k
so it is all pre-tax is that what you're
saying
um no the tap you will start to pay the
taxes
on on the vested shares but um yeah
and so you can't roll it into a 401k
then if it's not pre-taxed it can't be
rolled into a 401k
um yeah based on the paperwork here
um they're giving us the option to
um i guess move it into a 401k
i'm still looking at all the paperwork
here but yeah i double checked it
because
typically what they would do sean in
that scenario they would allow you to
take what you own in stock and then
purchase
new stock of the new company okay
like it may not be a traditional 401k
but just double check that but i'm going
to tell you buddy
how much debt do you guys owe on right
now outside of your home
uh we all want two vehicles that's 53
000.
how much money is this transfer going to
be worth
it's 1.477 million
this is her part correct
[Laughter]
wow i love it congratulations woo-hoo
seriously we feel like that we've won
the lottery yeah and
okay here's what you need to do you
don't need to ask two goobs on the radio
you need to get some tax advice
okay i want you to get some detailed tax
advice because there's too much money
involved here i can't tell
exactly what you've got from the way
you're describing it and i'm afraid i'm
going to mess you up
as far as taxes number one
i want to get the money out of that
single stock
as fast as i can into mutual funds
now you can do that inside of a 401k
inside of a rollover to an
ira or if you've got the ability to just
take the money out and only pay the
taxes on the gain
i can't tell what what is available to
you to shelter it
so what i would do if i were in your
shoes let's play this through
let's pretend this is pre-tax because it
sounds like it may be
okay and they're going to convert it to
stock and then i'm going to convert that
stock
into mutual funds inside the 401k
as fast as i can if you can move it
instead of the 401k into an individual
traditional ira with no taxes i'm going
to do that
with the bulk of this and i'm going to
pull out
400 grand and just pay taxes on it
because i think there's not going to be
penalties on it
and pay off your house and your cars
what's your home mortgage
uh we currently owe 126 000.
okay so 200 grand plus some taxes
gets you out of debt 100 right correct
out of 1.7 i'm definitely doing that
unless you're getting hit with the 10
penalty plus your tax rate and i don't
think you are
i think you're gonna get taxed at a
capital gains rate with no
i again you're going to have to get some
professional tax advice because i'm
going to screw this up
but yes i unless you're getting
absolutely hammered on the withdrawal
then i would pull enough out to be
debt-free and i would roll the rest of
it into mutual funds
into the 401k and i would move it into
some uh in an individual ira rollover
if i can get with one of the smartvestor
pros
and get online and get with one of our
tax pros if you don't have one in your
back pocket both of them are ill
or the elp for taxes and the smart
investor pro for investing they both can
tell you exactly what you've got because
i can't tell how this esop was set up i
can't either
and i want everybody else to calm down
out there because this is not how these
normally play out
this is the best version of this story
well it's an employee stock option
program
i mean he stopped and the thing just
went bananas it did
they got lucky wonderful but don't leave
your money in the new company stock
any longer than you have to run uber
high risk here
i want you to get out of that and get
into some diversified investments
where you can calm your risk down and
that way this money's gonna still be
sitting there that's right
congratulations that's so thrilling
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
matt and jamie are with us in sioux city
iowa hey guys how are you
we're good dave how are you better than
i deserve i see on my screen you're
debt-free congratulations
thank you we're excited how much have
you paid off
eighty one thousand two hundred forty
three dollars and ninety three cents
love it how long did that take roughly
16 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
um so our primary jobs have us right
about 50 take home
um and then the um four or five
side hustles that we did throughout that
time brought us up to about 80.
wow four to five you guys are after it
good what this of uh debt was the 81 000
uh so it was all student loans and 95 of
it was
probably me ah how long you guys been
married
just about a year and a half okay so you
get married and you started on this
boom just like that huh pretty much when
we were doing marriage prep
um my sister and her husband who have
been married for a few years
they introduced us to you um so we
started
you know reading your books listening to
podcasts and we were engaged
and then the day after the wedding we
got home
and drained my bank account um and
really just kind of started
wow went after it very cool so the
side hustles left and side hustles to
the right what was the
most lucrative per hour the best
side hustle um i would say probably
i bartended a couple different places i
would say the marina bar
or even during the pandemic once things
were shut down
and matt and i were both working from
home i started quilting and doing like
t-shirt quilts and baby quilts and
things like that
and i got faster at it so that turned
into pretty good
you know per hour wage that is fantastic
and looking at this so jamie did you
kick-start this
or did you guys kind of both come
together and agree
we both really agreed um i think matt
um because he was he was kind of the one
that was bringing in the student loans
um he got pretty intense about it and we
started
um you know even though we were still
engaged and we hadn't combined our
finances you know we were
doing the monthly budget we were
tracking everything we were spending
um and so that was kind of um how i had
lived i mean i worked
40 50 hours a week during undergrad so i
didn't have student loans um
and so once we got married we were
really on the same page which made it a
lot easier yeah that's fantastic i mean
when you guys are in this thing together
you know people rowing in the same
direction get to destinations faster
so very proud of you who encouraged you
all during this
during this time um i would definitely
say like jamie said her sister and her
brother
both of our parents were very much in
tune with it as well they were big
supporters of us
and you know just her and i like like
she said we
got very serious about this our first
year we did not live with heat or ac
one day it got to 49 degrees one night
and we just
we powered through it and now we are
currently living in a funeral home to
save on rent so we're we're all in on
this whole thing so it's it's pretty
pretty crazy
we got quite a story to tell wait a
minute here hold on just a minute
are you all working at this funeral home
or living there
um a little bit of both that's i guess
you can count that as one of my five
jobs um
it's you know it's just kind of as
needed basis on whatever they need help
with
but um i it was one of my gigs when i
was in college and then
when we moved back to the area you know
friends of ours had
run this funeral home and they said hey
do you want to live there in exchange
for some
extra hours that you're going to help us
so yeah you know hard to turn that down
well okay no it's not
hey you all are all in for sure yeah
you're gonna be killing your grandkids
yeah we lived in the funeral home that's
how we there's only
there's only been one really ghost story
so we're doing pretty well for having
lived there for a year and a half
so we're happy with it wow that's one
too many but i'm good yeah all right
i'm even more impressed with you all now
i was before but now
i think i think jamie comes from a
family that believes in working really
hard
yeah i mean her family's been farmers
for a long time and when i got there it
was
um like jamie had already had this
figured out on what
what work is and what you need to get
done and um
we need to spend money you need to have
money and we
don't do much of the spending so that's
kind of what i learned and
um yeah now we're now we're killing it
yeah so what do you guys tell people
the keys to getting out of debt are um
i would say um to be on the gentle edge
of just
grow up i would say you have to stop
buying into this myth
of instant gratification i think that's
something that our society has
kind of manipulated people into thinking
that you know everything is just right
there and it's
kind of what you said just do what feels
good um you know you have to kind of get
over that and work towards something
bigger and
and get rid of that you know instant
gratification um
that was the biggest thing i think for
us because there would be weekends that
we would work
40 45 hours in a three-day span and we
would make seven or eight hundred
dollars
but i didn't want to go to dairy queen
to spend six dollars to cap
off the weekend like we were just kind
of so
um you know gazelle intense that you
know we just really didn't want to break
from that
um and we really looked kind of beyond
that fleeting moment
well done well adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
you're right
yeah that's just absolutely vital so
well done
how does it feel now that you're there
i mean it's incredible we're starting to
you know jamie's gonna go to school here
again
pretty soon and we're already cash
flowing that um
you know it's just been part of the
process she got her master's degree we
cashflowed our wedding our honeymoon i
mean it's just that's how we're going to
start doing things and continue to do
things so
it's incredible that we don't have to
pay student loans every single month
that that chunk of change is coming out
automatically it's it's awesome to see
that the hard work we put in is staying
in our bank account
and we get to use it how we want to yeah
wow proud of y'all
very proud of you well done well hey
we're going to give you a copy of
chris's book
everyday millionaires and i'm also going
to give you some tickets to the
friday night valentine's weekend
special where john deloney and rachel
cruz are doing a money and marriage
event
so we're going to give you some tickets
for that you guys you guys need a night
off i'm just saying
wow yeah weekends with bernie and
everything oh my gosh
unbelievable wow so you guys are
impressive so well done you're absolute
rock stars i'm proud of you
very proud of you all right it is matt
and jamie 81
dollars paid off in 16 months making 50
to
80. and uh there's a great place to go
when you're broke
to work they proved it well done count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
great job i love it i love it
wow all right madison pick up and get
him a copy of chris's book plus get him
a copy of this upcoming event
it is this coming friday february the
12th the
marriage and money event with rachel
cruz and dr john delony
talking to you about the money and
marriage connection the communication
one of the things we have found over the
years for those of you that are
married it is absolutely vital that
you're on the same page
with money it changes your relationship
it changes the probability of your
wealth building
occurring everything it's only thirty
dollars
twenty dollars was the early bird ticket
so it's only thirty dollars a ticket
and uh you can enjoy this live stream
and uh this coming friday at 7
p.m central no matter what your marriage
looks like right now we can help you
achieve
better unity and communication at the
special valentine's
edition of money and marriage streaming
live to your home friday february 12th
at 7 pm
and again dr john deloney rachel cruz
one thing for sure
if those two are speaking there will be
humor
oh they're going to have fun the two of
them are they're just
funny we may have to be there to make
sure they do what they're doing exactly
yeah they got to hit the stuff they just
get to cutting up but listen i don't
know anybody else that does that stuff
no not you and i
we are straight laced that's right we
stay with the business always
we never we never stray never weekends
with bernie
twice or two or three times an hour
here's the deal if you're a part of
ramsay plus
you better get on over there and reserve
your seat because you get a chance to
check it out for
free it's a part of your membership man
check it out this is how it works
date night this is how it works i love
it
this is the ramsey chef
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsay show thank you for
joining us the phone number is triple
eight
eight two five five two two five adam is
in valdosta
georgia hi adam how are you hey dave hey
chris thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help i'm in a position
where
um with my career i'm trying to go back
to school and get a degree
to further my career and i'm in a
position where
it's possible that i may have to go into
debt
to get this degree um
with my career classes can be
transferred over into credit into this
specific
university online university and
there's no way i this only one that
moves all the classes i've ever taken
into
college credits so i'm trying to
struggle because i'm
i'm doing my debt snowball i'm
struggling with
handling the debt that i have and trying
to stay debt-free
for my degree and what's your degree
what's your degree field
i'm trying to get a bachelor's or
four-year degree in
business administration okay and how
much do you lack
um i have depending on how many
credit hours my classes for my career
move over
i have only my core classes so i'm
fairly fresh
into it so you got like three years of
work left
yeah i mean right and i could cut i
could cut that in half
almost if i go to this university
because it'll transfer all my career
stuff over
so you'd have a year and some change
left
you be in your senior year or late in
your junior year
correct okay all right and what do you
do for a living
i'm a firefighter okay how old are you
i am 26. okay and so the business degree
does what for you
it allows me for it's one of our uh
requirements for promotion in the future
as a firefighter you need a business
degree uh
as a uh higher level and administration
level uh
chief oh actually okay yeah
it's a further down on my career path
yeah
all right and how many years before you
would be eligible
for that um position if you had this
degree
if i had the degree i would say
roughly five to ten years
it's rough to say but at least five yeah
okay and um how many colleges are in
valdosta
um three i believe
okay yeah three yeah and you're
the one you're looking at though is
online correct
not one of those three no uh this is the
only
this university or the online university
is the only one that
moves all my clown i got that part i got
that
part have you talked to all three of the
others
i have
okay because they are much cheaper than
the online
yes a fourth aren't they
uh roughly yeah yeah so that's what
you're doing you're either gonna
go over there and talk one of them into
this
and uh appeal i mean sit down in the
president's office just stroll your butt
in there
and sit down and go i'm getting ready to
move everything to an online and pay too
much
for this degree because you guys won't
transfer these credits so we've got to
figure out something because this is
crazy i would rather
keep the money here in our community i'm
a firefighter here in this community
i'd rather keep the money here in the
community and support our local college
and
it's better for me to say i graduated
from this local community
and it is by the way right yeah
you're not going to go into debt and go
online
matter of fact i think the online idea
is just a bad idea because i think
you're paying way too much for the
stinking degree
that you don't need for seven years
right so i would just nix that and i i
think you just got to do some
politicking on the transfer
because the thing these are small
colleges this isn't like you're trying
to go
the freaking harvard and get them to
waive your you know accept your credits
right
this is valdosta state or whatever it is
for god's sakes
i mean it's not like it's it's not a i'm
not putting it down i'm you'll probably
get a great education there
but my point is you'll have access to
people probably that have an open mind
oh by the way they they actually want
students need
students they definitely i'm going to go
in there and find out what the appeals
process is or
who i have to appeal to or who who needs
to stroke a
agreement an executive order waiving
this or i don't know how it works even
yeah i wish dr john was here because he
would know
because it baffles me because even with
a community college they will take their
credits not give you the grace
some some of them but i mean i'm going
to communicate adam take the opportunity
or the thought of going into debt off
the table
exactly that's what i want you to do
just because right now you've got that
looking like it's the only option
to you and it's really not i'd much
rather you go
have that conversation go low and slow
as you're going part time
and it take you longer to get the degree
with avoiding debt we got 43 million
people walking around
with 1.7 trillion in student loan debt
you
you don't want to go there yeah and all
and a percentage of them
whining at the top of their lungs
expecting the government to forgive
their debt now
um we've got the um the lefties you know
going bananas on this stuff now
and so oh we should all have it forgiven
we should know and so
you know i'm going to be telling you no
no no no
no no now the other question that i
would bring into play here
i understand that you need the knowledge
pieces
to be an administrator in a leadership
position that high that
the the business leadership but um
i might even challenge that the degree
is a hundred percent a prerequisite for
you moving up into those roles
i think if you could exhibit and show
the knowledge that was in place
right you probably might you'd be
eligible for that
as well i i actually have never run into
that before but that doesn't mean
that you're not correct i'm just saying
i haven't run into it and so it does
make sense it's logical sense that to be
in an administrative role as senior
chief of the chief of uh
fire chief for the whole county or
whatever that kind of a thing that you
would need some
uh organizational administrative
uh skill sets that you would get in a
four-year business degree that
that's logical to me i'd even have a
conversation with the chief there to
find out can i
enroll in the national guard well or
will they pay for it yeah
i mean i want to have the conversation
on this to find out and understand it
more
uh but adam thanks for reaching out
buddy you can hear it's heavy on your
heart you need some more options and to
have some conversations
and keep gathering information the the
trick is as chris said take the debt off
the table it's not an option
and then from there what are we going to
do we've got to find another way to get
this goal accomplished
and that's what i keep poking out around
the edges here what are the options to
still accomplish the goal
with no debt yeah well and and you know
either cash flowing it
national guard fire department ships in
i don't care it doesn't matter to me i
hate that you would pay four times more
because you can't get the local college
to accept the transfer credits yeah
which is illogical by the way on top of
that so it means you got a good case as
far as i'm concerned
brenda is with us in oklahoma city hi
brenda
welcome to the ramsey show how can we
help hi
thank you um i want you to rethink
if you would buying personal defense
insurance
because i'm single i live alone
and i don't live in the best
neighborhood
and i've already bought it in all
actuality
and my son is a firm believer in you
he's coming home next month he's helping
me
go through my budget because he's
already succeeded with yours
what are you paying for this oh 179
a year and you mentioned he's gonna go
um right oh about 30 000 a year that's a
lot of money for you
and so basically if you pull your
handgun out and shoot a bad guy this is
supposed to protect you
it would because well i actually know
the
company yeah it's a really good company
there's there are some legitimate
companies in that space and there are
some companies that cover about half of
what they say they're going to cover too
so um i
mean i live in tennessee i i'm a handgun
enthusiast
i collect guns yeah uh i carry every day
um i don't have it and i make a lot more
than thirty thousand dollars
uh but the biggest insurance i've got is
i'm going to run
because i'm not pulling that gun out
right i'm going to run
that's right i'm going to run like like
my head's on fire yeah
so i i if you want to buy it it's okay
with me i mean it's nothing in the world
it's a lot of money for you honey
and i might think about spending 179 on
moving
um you know some other things like that
there's some other things to look at but
i
you have the you give the impression as
if this is somehow going to fix
everything
if you shoot somebody it's not it's not
it's going to ruin your life
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host chris hogan ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight
825-5225
eric starts off this hour in erie
pennsylvania hi eric how are you
hi i'm doing well dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
so i'm 19 years old i'm a full-time
college student
and i've just started um listening to
your show
i just got my car paid off so i have
zero debt
and i got into college with a lot of
scholarships and i'm also
very very fortunate to have a college
fund so i will be graduating with no
debt
i've been working hard throughout high
school and college since i was 15
and i have about 24 000 saved up between
my savings and investments and my
question is
should i start contributing to my roth
ira or should i
wait until i'm out of college and i've
started my career
man you're a rock star well done yeah
congratulations i'm proud of you man
very well done
um here's the thing you have plenty of
time after graduation to begin your
retirement
investing so if you graduate from school
get your first gig
your 401k roth there or your roth iras
and start from there on
you're go and you keep doing that from
22
until you're through your working
lifetime you're going to be a
multi-multi
millionaire plus you are not afraid of
hard work and you've been very
intentional with your money
very wise beyond your years and so if
you don't get crazy
you're going to be a multi multi multi
millionaire because it's the way you're
wired up
is you're heading in that direction
already the
best insurance that you have the best
income
is for you to finish your degree and
finish it without debt
as long as the degree is something
that's applicable and there's a job
market for it what are you studying
[Music]
um i'm studying communication sciences
and disorders and i'm going to go
for a master's degree in speech language
pathology phenomenal
excellent excellent so that is going to
afford you
an excellent income would you agree
yes okay so um translation
the money that you would put into a roth
the end of good mutual funds
the money it would make in the next
three years
compared to what you are going to be
worth as a result of graduating with
this degree
is is not even on the same chart you
are a much better investment than a roth
in mutual funds are
to finish your studies now i understand
you've got it mapped out
with scholarships and with a college
fund that you're going to go through
debt free
i heard that clearly and i heard that
you have twenty four thousand dollars
it wouldn't make me mad in other words
if you didn't start your roth
until after graduation and instead
ended up with i'm going to make up a
number 50 000 bucks in an account when
you graduate
you can start investing some of that
money then you can use it for transition
into your new career and move cities and
all that kind of a thing
have a fully funded emergency that's
like an insurance
policy to ensure that eric graduates
debt-free
yeah and eric what about the masters are
you going to be paying for that or is
your college fund going to pay for it
um my college fund is going to be paying
for it it's great
i'm actually in a five-year program so
i've already been
accepted into the master's degree
program and i know exactly how much it's
going to cost
not bad also roll over
so um i will be graduating 100
debt free well i'm proud of you buddy
and here's the beauty of it
while your college friends might be
eating ramen noodles you can upgrade
okay you got some money uh but be smart
and like dave said graduate have fifty
thousand
sitting there ready for you to jump
start life and be just hyper intentional
moving forward then
eric even if you wanted to park some of
it
into an investment say like a an index
fund
okay an s p 500 fund a no load fund
something like that
if you want to park some of it there and
begin some investing
that's okay i just wouldn't put it in a
retirement product
like a roth or a 401k because
my big goal for you is to finish this
wonderful track you have put yourself on
and uh man you've gotten some really
good coaching and advice
and you you know you're a very very
sharp young man
great job buddy excellent excellent work
angel is in tampa florida hi angel how
are you
hey good afternoon david chris uh thank
you for taking my call
sure how can we help well i have two
questions
one i want to start with i have an rv
that i purchased uh and i'm on my baby
step
two and i it's i owed 55
it's probably worth 45 so my question is
in baby step 2 do i just get
away or find a way to get rid of it even
if i have to carry
or maintain some kind of you know
balance
yes okay
yeah what do you make a year uh
72 yeah now this thing's insane
what's the payment on it oh it's nuts
it's
500. yeah yeah forever 500 months yeah
so what yeah you'd you're gonna end up
with a ten thousand dollar unsecured
loan at your credit union or your bank
to cover the deficit that you're in at
and because you've got to cover that
difference in order to sell it and get
the title correct
correct or the rv company okay or if the
rv company will carry it for you
yeah then i would let you do that as
well but yeah you need to get rid of it
and
you're gonna have to cover the
difference so but it's better to be ten
thousand dollars in death in 55.
absolutely and the 500 you've been used
to paying
that's going to allow you to again
you're going to go to that snowball
route
make minimum payments on everything but
the small one and once you chop that
down you're coming on down
and angel you're going to change your
kind of financial situation
uh with that but go talk to a credit
union or your bank
because this has to be unsecured in
order to release the title from the rv
company
yeah or if the whoever you've got the rv
loan with if they will agree to just let
you sign a note for the difference
if you've already got the loan over to
your local credit union for instance or
over at your local bank
you can get them to just allow you to
sign a note for the difference and
and you pay payments on that and put it
into your debt snowball but again it's
easier to get out of ten thousand than
55 and
and owning a 55 000 vehicle that's going
down in value like a rock
sitting in your driveway when you make
75 is a mathematical
using it twice a year crazy land yeah
no it's got to go you got to get rid of
it
you don't own any rvs i don't why
uh i i waste my money on other things
i do waste money i mean because i own
two boats and two seadoos and that right
there
offset us rv right and so i mean i got
two ski boats but
but again they're a very small
percentage not only of my net worth
but of my income but they are also used
and
and well um the one when i bought it i
bought one of them
no no i meant they're used throughout
the year oh you're always
you know riding around behind that boat
all the time but yeah but but i mean he
may be using the rv he we don't know
he's not using it but
um the abode and rv all these things are
toys
right and there's nothing wrong with
having a side-by-side or
you know getting a snowmobile or
whatever it is you want to get this a
toy
but all the things that you number one
you gotta pay cash for it and all the
things that you own with wheels motors
and them they go down in value so they
should add up to no more than half your
annual
income because otherwise you have too
much juice tied up
and stuff going down instead of yeah
that's not good pretty simple math
formula
this is the dave duh the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost sharing ministry
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality
is my co-host today thank you for
joining us this is the ramsay show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five tony is with us in sioux
falls south dakota hi tony welcome to
the
ramsey show how can we help good
afternoon gentlemen thanks for taking my
call
hey my question is i get a my company
leases a vehicle back from me
i'm currently on steps four five and six
and it's about eight hundred and fifty
dollars a month
and it the over the last ten years i've
used that fund i've just put it in a
savings account and
gained zero interest on it to buy my
vehicle with cash every time
and i'm just looking at i'm wondering
what to do with that money
this time around if it's a money market
uh mutual funds
savings account what's the best option
well if you put it into a
mutual fund you stand the probability of
it going down in value not
just up right correct
and i know you say if they're not going
to leave it in five years and not
go into a mutual fund yeah um this last
this last time it was actually about
five and a half years when i used
the funds well i mean you could you
could split it up and you could put half
into a
s p 500 and a half into a money market
and then you're not putting it
all at risk of going down if you want to
try to let it earn a little bit
um the trick is that the system is
what's going to save your butt
not the fact that you had it invested
okay how much money are what you're
talking you're talking about you said
800 a month and you're putting it all
aside for car replacement right
correct it's about ten thousand dollars
a year and at the end of the uh
i usually run the vehicles to about 200
to 250 i'd like to run them as long as
they can
yeah and uh let's say over that five
year period of time then let's say it
averaged twenty five thousand dollars
because fifty thousand in five years so
it averages
median the median point is 25k and so if
you make 10
on 25k that's 2 500
uh which does not impact a fifty
thousand dollar situation that much
okay so what you earn on this money is
not as important as the fact that you
have a system
to keep yourself from going into debt
so it would be okay to earn nothing then
as long as i'm continuing with
yeah because it's the the investment but
if you were going to leave it alone
20 years and you left it at one percent
well that'd be ludicrous right
yeah yeah and tony i mean you've got an
opportunity to be able to put half of
that aside for car replacement you could
throw the other half your cedron four
five and six
you could throw that toward the mortgage
you know the point is
you want the money to work for you don't
put any more in this car replacement
fund
then you need to replace the car right
and so whatever the schedule is
on that and again if you want to just
just to dial it up a little bit
move half of it into mutual funds and
into an s p 500 and the other half
just let it ride on a thing i mean
let it ride in a money market account
but but the whatever you earn on it even
if you earn
really good money is not going to
substantially change
your life what is substantially changing
your life
is you've been smart enough to avoid
debt and you have a system to replace
these cars as you after you wear them
out
and you are destroying them because
you're the number of miles you're
putting on them
i mean you're just wearing them out and
that's uh your road warrior that's part
of the cost of doing business in your
world
nothing wrong with that but at least
you've figured out how to admit it
and uh that's pretty cool and you also
figured out the 800
a month doesn't cover all your costs so
uh they're
they're giving you uh some money but
they not giving you a company car
you'd have been better off with a
company car a lot
better off all right dave is with us in
dallas hi
dave welcome to the ramsey show how can
we help
hey dave i'm uh trying to determine
whether or not i should
do a deferred income annuity
why would you do that well
my financial person
suggested it because i'm i'm real
fearful fearful of the
other market crash and
she's like well you know if the market
crashes you know the he's losing the
value
of our retirement right now i'm i'm
retired
uh my wife is fixing to retire
i'm 58. how much money is it retired at
55
and uh how much money is it we've got
2.3
and you're fearful that the market is
going to completely destroy
well not completely but uh you know
half and then if i'm withdrawing
and where in history have you seen it do
that
okay uh you're right you're right uh or
30 i guess and where in history have you
seen it do that
i thought 2008 was somewhere around
there no it was half
i went from 30 the dow went from 13 to 6
700.
okay and it was back in a year
right and now it's not 6700 or 13.
it's 30 000 right correct okay
so unless you have a need for 2.5
million dollars
at the bottom of the market you would
not embrace the 30 percent loss you
would ride it out wouldn't you
yes even though i'm going to be
withdrawing
you know 10 grand a month which is a
whole 120 000
a year that's not even the growth okay
okay dave listen yes sir listen my
friend
you are an everyday millionaire you have
been intentional in growing this money
you're going to be fine i i listen
the thing is this okay i understand
that the world is unraveling out here in
front of us i'm watching it too
i'm not disagreeing with you about that
but we
we dr daloni talks about when we're in a
crisis situation or when we're in a
situation
facts are our friends not fear
and if the facts say if there's some
actual
facts that indicate that we're going to
have a substantial
market drop and it's going to maintain
and it's going to stay down there
then we would have this discussion i
don't have any of those facts
the only thing i've got is i don't like
the socialist
tendencies that are in dc right now
i don't like the idea of heavy taxation
i don't like what they're going to do to
the economy
uh overall i don't think it's going to
be pleasant but i don't think we're
going to see a market correction of 30
percent
i'm 60 i have pulled zero
out of the market due to my being upset
about the current world that i live in
does that make sense
yes so while i have those emotions i
have to gauge
the actual facts of the history to do
that
so all of that said i'm not sure i would
do a deferred income annuity i might do
a
variable annuity and a variable annuity
will give you
principal protection and a floor of a
minimum
gain or a minimum increase in value
usually five percent six percent
and you're invested in vehicles that are
going to make you 10 to 12
on average but if the market really
tanked you'd have principal protection
and you would have uh uh
you know a floor for the earnings and so
if if that will make you sleep better at
night
you're going to pay an extra fee for
that
variable annuity that you really don't
need it doesn't give you anything that
you need
except that peace of mind that you're
looking for so you're paying for that
now would i move the whole two million
dollars in there absolutely not
but but would i move in your case if you
still
think this through and you still are
worried about it uh
you know then you know you might move
500 700 in there maybe move a third of
your
of your net worth into that it's not a
bad place because you can put it in good
mutual funds you'll still have a similar
growth rate
you're just going to have a higher
expense ratios okay
and when you pull money out of it it's
no longer going to be taxed at
uh well it's it's in a it's all in 401ks
anyway isn't it
correct yeah you're going to be tax
ordinary income anyway when you come out
but um oh no oh i'm sorry uh
right now no mine's not in 401ks
uh all of mine is sort of the majority
of mine
is in um irs okay
but if you have non you see you're taxed
at ordinary income when you pull it out
of a traditional ira
and so when you pull it out of this
you're going to be tax ordinary income
too so that doesn't harm you much
if you're dealing with non-retirement
money putting into a variable annuity
you're going to
change from capital gains taxation to
ordinary income taxation which is
something else to consider but that's
not your case yeah so maybe a third of
it dave but the other thing i would do
is i'd spend some more time
learning about history and let facts be
your friends
even though we're scared
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host
thank you for joining us america you're
listening to the ramsay show
i'm dave ramsey your host kyle is with
us in
fayetteville north carolina hey kyle how
are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call i got
a quick question about
a little bit of extra money that i got
where i should be putting it
i say i should be putting it extra
towards my mutual funds my wife wants to
pay off the rental properties
your wife would be right
so even if i plan on selling those
rental properties when i retire out of
the military in four years
we'll go and sell them now
i could do that okay
but they're they're they're still making
me a little bit of money and so when i
retire i think the key here is a little
bit
yeah but kyle think about it that same
mindset you have of wanting to put the
money into mutual funds
for it to be able to grow long-term for
you if you go ahead and sell them now
and take that equity
finish cleaning up whatever debt you
have and now you invest that now you're
on a serious long-term growth plan
yeah here's the thing
you're not really making any money on
these rental properties
are you um
not real money i mean i'm making close
to 750 a month off the rentals and it's
paying down the
mortgage and you know building equity
750 minus
vacancy minus repairs
yes yeah so
you know really we're talking about
three or four thousand dollars a year
and you're how far in debt on the rental
properties
uh total it's four 437.
437 thousand dollars worth of risk to
make three thousand dollars a year
that does not make sense when you said a
little bit of money
i knew what you were talking about see i
love real estate
but real estate is not a good investment
the way you've done it
because this is probably it has as much
chance of costing you money
at the end of the story as it does
making you money so
i think you're both going to get your
wish i would sell the rentals
now because i don't think they're a
blessing
and i want you to buy rentals later and
pay cash for them
in your wealth building journey but not
this year and maybe after you get out of
the military and
maybe after you decide where you're
going to settle and all of those kinds
of things but
right now i'm going to go ahead and
invest that money in mutual funds like
you wanted to do yeah kyle thank you for
your service by the way but i knew dave
was about to do a math lesson on you
i knew it because i've been around
enough and i've heard it
and unfortunately you know when we see
it for what it is you see those numbers
the real way
and you start to identify you're only
making about three grand a year
and taking on that level of risk you can
quickly identify that it's not worth it
well there is something that has risen
up
um in the um
20s the 20 year olds 20 to 30 year olds
even 20 to 35 year olds right now that
we're seeing
almost on a moment-by-moment basis in
all of our interactions
uh with you guys out there through
broadcasting and through all the other
ways we interact with you
uh the positive is there's this
tremendous
that this generation whatever we're
calling these 20-somethings
um has this tremendous entrepreneurial
zeal in drive
and this this this sense to be
independent it's not greed driven
it's uh initiative it's very positive
it really is it's a wonderful character
attribute you've got that that's how you
got these rental properties
and that drive is causing these
20-somethings
to do two things and oftentimes poorly
because they're doing them too quickly i
did this in my 20s
but i'm a boomer which now is a put down
but it used to be just a demographic but
um
but uh now i've got old man house shoes
you know so there you go
but the uh uh the the this wonderful
zeal this wonderful entrepreneurial zeal
is causing
these 20-somethings to buy real estate
so i gotta buy real estate
i'm gonna get rich in real estate i'm
gonna get rich in real estate man when i
was in my 20s
is when infomercials started oh that was
the beginning of infomercial oh yes
i'm going to get rich in real estate i'm
going to get rich in real estate
and i grew up in the real estate
business and so i went straight into i'm
going to get rich in real estate and i
did i became a millionaire by the time i
was 26 and
uh the other it's driving this bitcoin
craze it's driving this gamestop crate
yes
yes uh the same zeal is driving
people to do these things and to get out
there and i'm gonna turn i'm gonna do
something
i'm gonna get something i'm gonna and
it's not greed it's the
spirit on it i mean the my discernment
says it's not greed it is
initiative it's it's a positive ambition
but what caused what happened with me
was i bought real estate that i couldn't
afford
i leveraged it i used totally borrowed
money and i ended up with 4 million
worth of real estate that i owed 3
million on so i had a million dollar net
worth
but it wasn't cash flowing and i was
flipping it and it was barely cash
flowing like his is barely cash flowing
this is why i know this math because i
lived it
right because i did the same thing only
i did it with more zeros on the end it
wasn't 400 000 is 4 million
and it took me down because the bank got
uh sold and called our notes
and uh then i and i didn't have any cash
i was not in it
i had all these assets but there was no
cash
[Music]
and when you do that with real estate is
when you're gonna go broke not when
you're gonna make a fortune in real
estate
and so real estate that does not have
margin
is not a blessing it's a liability and
investing in things that don't have
margin or
that are a high risk gamble play
is a misuse of your entrepreneurial
ambitious zeal
and so i love the zeal what i want to do
is channel it
with some wisdom and a process some
wisdom
yes and that is slow down a little bit
yeah and pay cash and don't
invest everything you have in super high
risk crap
um i mean and i i know there's stories
of people making money in bitcoin i know
there's stories of people making money
with gamestop we talked to one here on
the other day i'm not saying it can't
happen
but i know stories of people make money
at the roulette wheel too that's right
i know people that made money on wheel
of fortune but that doesn't mean
our jeopardy i've got personal friends
that that won
uh and they won 50 000 bucks or
something but they didn't change their
career to be game show operators
right and they didn't put everything
they had that didn't push all their
chips to the center of the table on one
hand of cards
and that's what we're doing when we go
into highly leveraged real estate
into businesses with no margin or high
risk investment plays
and we act like it's a freaking game
right because we put all the chips in
the center table now if you've got a
small percentage of your chips and
you're
going to lose those and it doesn't kill
you that's different i don't even
recommend that but i'm not going to make
fun of you for that
right i am going to call you out on the
other because this this
you know it leads to uh bad critical
thinking that
okay real estate's a good investment so
all real estate no matter how broke i am
is a good investment that's right
that's bad thinking skills it is and
that's what happened with
in the 90s with day trading uh it's what
we're seeing now with bitcoin and
gamestop
uh but i'm gonna tell you something dave
i'm getting these callers calling in
these millennials
on my show the chris hogan show that are
saving and investing and following the
plan and the trail
is the foundations course they took in
high school
that they were either financial peace
babies where their parents went through
it
taught them or they went through
foundations and so they've got this
learning foundation literally where
they're thinking and following the
process
yeah it's encouraging i had people you
know when i'm doing real estate deals
i had people that thought i was a genius
when i was buying all that real estate
um except the old people
and the old people that had money kept
looking at me going son you're too
leveraged you got no cash
this is going to catch up with you
you're going to get a spanking
you're going to get it and i kept going
oh you're this old you don't understand
this is a proper use of capital markets
and i used all the cash flows
you know i've got great internal rates
of return
i have no cash right no liquidity i
couldn't buy a freaking loaf of bread
you know but i got four million dollars
in real estate and so
this idea that you can throw around all
your arrogant little terms and all they
show is your immaturity
they don't show that i'm a dinosaur they
show that you're a child
that's all it shows and so the thing is
use this ambition this movement which is
so positive in this generation
in a slower more methodical cash basis
way
with high margins and then you're going
to learn love real estate i got a bunch
of real estate
and i want you to have some too i just
don't want to have you there it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well tax season is here
i know that's exciting oh goody dave
thanks for the help the reason i want to
say that listen you got to do your taxes
early
the reason you do them early not in
march or april is because you're going
to be under far less stress and less
stress means less mistakes
plus if you actually owe taxes filing
early means you can start saving
or being ready to file early even if you
need to if you need to save up and wait
until april 15th actually pull the
trigger
on the file you'll at least know what
the target is right if you need a tax
pro
you need to get with one right now
before they get busy you get busy
you know this is the sooner you reach
out to a tax pro the better
and that way your taxes get done way
before the deadline and then you can
decide a strategy for this year and what
you need to do
text the word tax pro to 33789
and we'll hook you up with one of our
tax endorsed local providers
text tax pro one word to
33789
and you'll find a tax pro that chris and
i and all the ramsey personalities
endorse
and think are awesome seriously clemmy
is with us clemmy is in uh atlanta
georgia is it clemmy is that correct
yes sorry how can we help hey how you
doing fellas
hey so i've got a question i'm in a job
um that i love
and with my uh career trajectory um i
plan on i'm assistant manager at the
retail store
and within the next year or so i'm going
to bump up to a
store manager and write that out for
another five years
and stay with the company and go to um
corporate office after that
but my quandary is that i have
credit card quoted to me and it goes
against everything that i believe
in and i have to push these get stored
credit cards
and i'm having a hard time um
doing my job effectively and also and
also i don't want that to um hinder me
from moving up within my company so i'm
at a loss of what to do in this regard
how long have you been with him
uh since 2016. so i'm we're going on
five years
what do you make i'm almost 60.
how big a knot is in your stomach
well listening to you every day doesn't
help
[Laughter]
sorry about that
i'm really brother something i don't
believe in him let me
listen brother my friend i crossed that
same path
and here's the reality it is truly a
matter of you
coming to understand that the skill set
that you've been blessed to have
the way that you work the way that you
serve customer service and sales
that same skill set can be used
elsewhere
without you having to have a conflict of
what you believe in
and it's going to require you to have
that thought process
before you gain clarity and i would tell
you what i did was i started to write
down
options where where else can i go
and help people and serve well without
having to do something i don't believe
in
and i'm going to tell you in that
industry it's not going to go away
you're not going to be able to miss this
in order to move up you're going to have
to embrace it and
and not only embrace it do it well so
that's where you're going to have that
crisis of kind of internal conflict
you're going to have to change
industries but that doesn't mean you
can't still can't serve people
now here two or three things come to
mind one is you've got a detailed
career path laid out in your mind with
this company
so you're not abandoning a 60 000 your
job that you hate
no you're abandoning a dream that you've
had yeah
yeah if you leave this company and
that's going to be very hard to do
that's why this conflict is so real and
i'm not suggesting that you
have to do this on principle you're
calling and saying
that the principles are that you feel
like you're in conflict
so one thing is i think you need to it's
going to take you a little while
and you don't have to panic and you're
not stealing from you're not stealing
bubble gum from little children i mean
this is not
you know you're not you know you're just
doing something that you don't feel
good about that you wouldn't do for your
own kids you wouldn't do for your mama
and you know so you're violating your
conscience in that regard
and so but but it's not you're not
you're not doing anything illegal and
you're not doing anything immoral
uh so i would take my time and
work my way into a new dream
a new career path that uh that i can
begin working on and
so you know embrace some of ken
coleman's materials at kingcoleman.com
and you know the proximity principle
book will give you a copy i'll have
madison pick up and give you a copy
so that's kind of thing one is there's a
real emotional
process that probably is going to take
more than 10 minutes
okay if they came in and said you had to
do something
illegal that would take you about a
minute and a half to walk out the door
right absolutely but but this is not
this is not that situation this is just
a
this is a rub is what this is but it's a
rub it's like chris said it's not going
away now
the second thing is to embrace what
chris's
portion of advice was one of my favorite
books on business that i've ever read is
by our friend rabbi daniel lapin and
it's called thou shall prosper
and rabbi lapin as you can obviously
guess is a jewish orthodox rabbi
and the book is the 10 reasons that
jewish people have had a tendency to
prosper
throughout history beyond the population
that they've been installed in
and so for instance uh three percent of
americans are jewish 67 percent of the
forbes 400 is
so these are 10 principles we all want
to know right those of us that aren't
jewish but
rabbi and i have become really good
friends over the years and one of the 10
principles
is that over a long period of time
it is almost impossible for someone to
prosper
doing something that they don't believe
to be morally correct yes
so it's going to be very difficult over
the next 10 years
for your dream path to actually occur
because you have this other you know
knot
in your stomach and you know and i'm
sorry i put it there but i'm
glad you recognized it i mean i i again
i'm not pounding my fist and yelling
that this company is horrible or
something they're just a retail company
selling credit cards they all do
and my goal is that one day uh enough
americans wake up and realize
that the credit card is basically the
cigarette of the financial world
that companies like this quit doing that
because the
public pressure forces them to like the
public pressure is forced to change in
smoking you know when i was growing up
you could smoke on an airplane
a metal tube with people in it full of
smoke i mean it's just amazing in the
air
it's just and the funniest one was when
they went to no smoking sections
yes as if as if as if the magic you were
exhausted it's like the no p
into the pool i mean you know it's like
it doesn't go to the other end of the
pool come on
and so um you know but anyway that you
know that's what's going to happen if as
we continue to
have more and more and more people
understand that living debt-free
is a fabulous way of doing it it really
is and clemmy i'm going to tell you
that little knot that you have right now
is only going to continue to grow
so i i am too but i'm excited for you
the thing that
that i got to was that it was a matter
of the lord had something else for me to
do
and so having that awareness as dave
said you do shift the dream
but you do understand that you're still
able to serve people and use the skill
set you've been
blessed to have and that you've polished
and so again
we get ken's book we're going to send
you a copy i want you to read it
but start to lay out options and i'm
proud of you for reaching out and
talking about this
uh early on uh it was something i
struggled with before i reached out to a
mentor to discuss
yeah i think the options is a big deal
when you've got a new
dream that is as detailed as your
current dream oh man
oh game changer in a different area
that's not going to cause you these
knots in your stomach yeah
then making the change will be easy
right now the idea of making the changes
going from this
dialed in path to nothing yep and that's
not a jump anybody can make emotionally
if you're wise
your emotions will stop you from doing
that and they should so take your time
and let's get a new dream
detailed out a new path that says i'm
going to work here
and then i'm going to be a store manager
and then i'm going to be original
manager and then i'm going to work in
the home office and whatever it is i
mean
you had it laid out i mean you got it
dialed in and uh but i
i wish i could tell you that the big box
whatever it is uh retailer home depot
they'll wake up uh lowe's uh whoever it
is you know
walmart whoever it is i don't know who
it is that i wish i could tell you they
were going to quit pedaling credit cards
soon enough for your dream to come true
but they're not no they're not
um targeting we're going to keep working
on them at ramsay though yeah we are
until we bother them enough that enough
people start to realize that i think we
can change
and create a whole movement i think we
are we are we are going to create a home
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host chris hogan ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five jacob is with us in danbury
connecticut hi jacob welcome to the day
to the ramsay show how can we help
hey dave chris uh thanks for having me
how are you guys better than we deserve
how can we help
um just got a question about a 401k
investment
retirement investment right now i have a
traditional 401k and i'm looking to go
to a roth 401k
i just have a question on the best way
to do that if i have to do it all at
once with the taxes or
if there's a steps i can take to kind of
cut down on the amount of
i have to pay out yeah well the first
thing is just stop doing
new except roth let all your new
contributions be roth from this point
forward that's step one
okay now how much is in your 401 k in
the traditional
uh about 50 000 right now okay and what
baby step are you on
i am on data step four okay then i would
not convert the 50 000 until after your
home is paid off
okay because it's gonna create about
twelve thousand dollars in taxes
and i would rather you use those twelve
thousand dollars for your five or six
baby step
but later on when you're in baby step
seven and you scratch up some extra cash
then yeah go ahead and flip it uh flip
it on over into the roth at that point
but uh it won't hurt anything for it to
sit there and grow as traditional
for a couple of years while you get the
house paid off
okay um i i do have another question
about
mutual funds um right now i do have
a portfolio it's kind of a slow growth
i'm just wondering what the best mutual
fund that you would recommend to
invest in non-retirement
non-retirement why would you have
non-retirement
um i don't know if if it's something
that i may
need to pull out of it or how much is in
it
i have about seventy thousand
what's the balance on your home
about seventy huh i think we just found
a use for it
jacob did you feel that that was a
seismic shift
right there for you buddy you have an
average what do you make a year
uh well this is actually the first year
with a bunch of overtime
i just pulled in about 120. way to go
man
and your debt-free house and everything
i'm so proud of you
game-changer jacob yeah seriously
brother
hey man cash it out pay off your house
now let's take that house payment and
let's uh
save up twelve thousand dollars and
convert the rest of that 401k to a roth
and then let's start maxing everything
out and uh then let's just start piling
up some cash and being
unreasonably outrageously generous you
are so cool man he is seriously
i mean a young man that has listened and
followed the principles
uh is about 100 desperate i mean for the
most part
mostly you know but now he's got a
chance to kind of right the ship and get
himself from moving in the right
direction
so for clarification for those of you
that are just kind of in the middle of
you know what a baby step is but you're
not sure about the nuances
whatever money you have in anything
that is not in a retirement account
should be liquidated and used for
whatever step you are on
yes step one's a thousand dollars two is
debt-free everything but the house three
is an emergency fund
four is 15 of your income going into
retirement five is kids college
if that's if that's applicable if not we
head straight on to six and pay off the
house
that's how i did that right but
non-retirement accounts dave can look
like what
a brokerage account a mutual fund
investment seventy thousand dollars with
a seventy thousand dollar mortgages an
inheritance
all of these things yeah yeah the money
is sitting there from you got some stock
your grandpa gave you you got
seven thousand dollars in savings bonds
that granny gave you you've got
five gold coins that you don't that you
don't even know how you got them or why
you got them or i don't know what it is
what have you got
that is just sitting around it's an
investment use it for the baby step
that you're on because the shortest
distance between where you are today
and wealthy and outrageously generous is
walking those baby steps exactly and as
quickly
as you possibly can don't change the
recipe okay
any times people tell me chris you know
i'm following baby steps ish
i'm doing ramsay-ish i'm like stop doing
ish and do
it yeah follow it to a t we've had
millions of people get help
why are you overthinking the wheel it
works hey we're even walking with our
thousand
team members this year yeah our internal
vision for the year is to walk the talk
and so everybody's going through
financial peace university again
we're dialing in so that our own team
members are not doing
ish that's right and uh we're even doing
t-shirts issues of wish
hogan's got hogan's saying on the
t-shirt issues of which i like it
but seriously got an opportunity right
now where you are
uh to make a decision and if you're not
a part of ramsey plus i'm telling you
right now get over there
we are adding more information and more
content at all times
you have an opportunity to get connected
with the events that we have
via live stream because you're a member
of ramsey plus
so text the word trial to 33789
again the trial is the word text that to
33789
and come on in yeah if you're brand new
the thing is that he
he's right that we've got this whole
thing we just installed it's
in about in the last six months or so
where the first 90 days
we give you small consistent wins not
just the baby steps but every little
detail
leading up into a baby step small
consistent wins these add up to big
results and
better habits and that means you're
going to get where you want to be
faster so free trial
by texting the word trial 23789
now if you're a member by friday night
we've got the money and marriage event
friday night and it is 30
if you want to watch it as a live stream
rachel cruz and
dr john deloney talking about marriage
and money it'll be fun funny and
informative
uh great holla a great valentine's day
gift but if you're a member ramsey plus
it's free yup most of our live streams
are free to ramsey plus members
in addition to financial peace
university in addition to premium
version of every dollar
all of that's all wrapped up there to
make sure you get what you need and that
we're
able to walk with you and show you how
to do that but the trick is
there's kind of a spillover effect you
know like one of those water wheels
coming around as the water
fills up one area it moves one more time
spills out that's how the baby steps
work it does
any of the water that you've got you put
it in that bucket
yeah until that bucket's full and it
spills over the next one move on and
then any other water you get
whether it's from your budget or the
gold coins in your safe
or you're gonna sell i don't know
grandpa's whatever
i don't know what it is this thing
you've been hanging on to it really is
not an asset it's just sitting over
there on its butt looking at you
and the only thing we don't do is we
don't cash out retirement to do that
because of the penalties and the taxes
are so heavy
and it makes it just it takes the fun
out of it i'm telling you you got a
great opportunity
change your future change your mindset
and if you change your mindset
i'm telling you you can change your life
yeah so come over to ramsey plus check
it out
jacob's in a great place yes he is he's
debt free house and everything you just
helped him if he does what we told him
to do he better follow the directions
jake today jay
right now don't make us come to
connecticut
please no it's cold i can't go up there
i can't go please don't make me nope
i'll text you
please i don't i'll do anything
i would almost pay off your house to
keep from coming not really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable
prices and they make it simple to shop
blinds shades and interior shutters with
easy online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
we invite your calls at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five our question today comes
from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month
you save even more use the magic word
the promo code ramsey
all right today's question comes from
dave in kentucky
uh he says i lost my wife in december of
2020
my goodness i have an eight-year-old
that will start receiving survivor
benefits
of 858 dollars per month from social
security
by the time she reaches 18 the total of
those payments will be around 100 000
what would be the best thing to do with
the money so it earns
interest and is worth more once she's
18.
wow well i'm dave i'm so sorry to hear
about your loss my friend
um that's tough and i can't imagine uh
what you're going through i hope you got
a good church and good friends around
you
but looking at this this dollar amount
this 858 survivor benefits coming in
this has got to become part of your
budget uh you're going to use this to
raise your daughter
yeah what whatever whatever baby step
you're on and
if you'll follow the stuff we teach by
the time she's 18 you'll you will have
fully funded her college fund and she'll
have a lot more than a hundred thousand
dollars
and you will have become wealthy
over that 20 years and she will have a
lot more than a hundred thousand dollars
and so there's not any moral ethical nor
legal obligation for you to set this
money aside
in her name you spend more than 858
raising a kid a month anyway and so just
put it into your budget and work your
budget
because we're counting on you to be a
great dad and anytime you work your
budget it is for the good of you and
your family yeah
and so your daughter is going to more
than benefit
far beyond what the 858 dollars would
have done right by you doing the right
thing
people struggle with this child support
i should set it aside
right no it's all part of the budget
because you spend more than those
dollar figures on kids anyway yeah just
to raise them yeah no without a doubt i
mean the percentage of the
the roof replacement the percentage of
the
electric bill the percentage of the
insurance that the kid rides in the car
the cost of the car the value of the
loss in the car
the kid is receiving the benefit of all
of that and this is called raising your
children
in a family it's what it is and so
mathematically you spend
a lot more than that on the kids portion
of your life
yeah and so there's no you've done
nothing
wrong uh by not setting it into a
separate account
and as a matter of fact setting it into
a separate account i think would be
wrong
yeah it's the improper use of it it's
not the most efficient use of the money
so good question natalie is in canada hi
natalie
welcome to the ramsey show hi
dave thank you for taking my call
um i'm trying to figure out a few things
but the main thing is
whether or not to uh try and get my
husband on board with selling our house
i've brought it up a few times but he
really doesn't want to sell it at a loss
we moved
a year ago about an hour and a half away
from his current work
he planned on getting job job around
where we live
we live in the middle of nowhere um with
the intention of being able to grow our
own food and just
be out in the country again where we
both kind of grew up
and um anyway it hasn't happened yet
he's trying but
it hasn't happened we just realized we
were expecting
another so we've got one toddler and
another on the way
um so he has a job it's just an hour
away
an hour and a half yes so he's traveling
about three hours a day
but the income is uh he takes home about
uh
31 000 and some uh 30
almost uh 31 200 a month
and um we don't have any
um uh real issues exposed with spending
that we're aware we don't you know we
don't have any money subscriptions
we don't have any money no we don't have
any money
thirty one thousand in the three hour
drive a day i know where your money
and babies i mean you're only any money
no
i i don't know how to convince them
we're we're both believers um
unfortunately because of covet all the
churches are shut down the one we did
get to know it's closed now
and we really haven't developed any
sense of community around here
how much do you owe on the home natalie
okay uh so so far we have
we oh it's around
280 000. okay uh
it was 300 just under 350 000 when we
lost how are you making a payment on
that making 31 grand
well we're losing we're leaving every
month how
um we
yeah i would guess how much is your
house one thousand payment
hundred and eighty three dollars and how
much do you all have in savings right
now
oh we're burning through it uh we've
probably got
yeah right now brought a thousand
nine hundred left to our names in liquid
and you're burning how much no um
we are burning i wrote this down too got
all kinds of papers in front of me
um two thousand seven hundred and seven
dollars and forty
so you don't even have a month left
not really no not really i mean two
thousand over nineteen hundred you don't
have any money left
yeah i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do um
i'm trying to say okay i i don't know
let me okay i'm a little bit confused
let me let me stop
i don't want to uh i don't want to
take your side and jump all over him
right now but that's how i'm no
no that's how i'm feeling i don't like
well because this is absolutely asinine
that you guys have let this that you've
let this burn down to this y'all should
have been out of there six months ago
i agree and so i don't i don't
understand why we're in denial about
math what's his problem
he doesn't want to show that a loss i
don't care he's going to lose it to
foreclosure
i know but you said you bought it at 350
correct
and it's now you 0280 so what's it what
do you think it's worth now
i wish i knew we haven't gotten the
price okay
so here's the steps i think in sitting
down and really sitting down with him
hold his hands and i want you to
schedule i've scheduled a
real estate agent to come over here
tomorrow night because tonight we're
about to have a come to jesus meeting
the math is over we cannot that we
cannot pretend anymore
you've got your head stuck up something
i don't know what it is and it's got to
come out yeah this is ridiculous
and put put his hand on your belly and
let him know you've got another baby
coming
this is crazy time time is at the end i
have i have he's even finished your book
we bought your book on amazon
he read it he's so excited so gung-ho
he's not
going to look for more jobs now but it's
it's just it's not about jobs it's about
this house is gone
yeah yeah yeah it's gotta be it's a
three-hour drive
with a pregnant wife who's scared and
he's out of money this house is gone
sell it before you lose it yeah what do
we do do we rent
or um you move to town and rent when we
went there
it was eighteen hundred a month you're
gonna have to get other jobs but listen
what your your little dream of living in
the country and growing veggies has
turned into a nightmare yeah
yeah i know and so something's got to
change we can
you cannot stay where you are yeah it's
not going to work now then the only
question is where are we going
right and you got to start figuring that
out as a next step but this i
i i don't know what you were waiting on
were you waiting on the housing ferry to
show up
i mean it's not this isn't you know
unless you were going to have an income
all of a sudden start appearing that's
double yours yeah it's not gonna work
this is not gonna work
it's not just and so natalie the urgency
you hear in our voice
is that we don't want you all hanging
out for another two to three months you
don't have that
you're never gonna come get the house
yeah you don't have that time
so i would much rather you all make a
proactive decision reach out to your
lender have a real conversation
get the real estate agent the real
estate elp over tomorrow
you are moving yeah voluntarily
or otherwise you are moving much rather
you be in control
this is where you are and so let's face
it and decide what we're going to do
where are we moving because we're moving
this house is gone i'm so sorry i'm
sorry you guys have been through this
but you've i you got to deal with it you
cannot
you cannot not deal with it anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five drew is with us in
chicago
hi drew welcome to the ramsey show how
can we help
hi how are you great it's a pleasure to
speak with both of you
too um so uh my wife and i
uh have been davish for years uh last
march
i was able to get my wife uh 100 percent
on board
uh i'm sure the pandemic had a little
bit to do with that
so we started using the every dollar
budget uh which allowed us to
pay off our uh only vehicle loan um
got rid of all the credit cards that we
had wonderful um
cash flowed three kids uh braces uh and
we've
got a fully funded emergency fund now
how does that feel
ah it feels fantastic good fantastic
how's it feel to hurt her
i'm sorry i said how does it feel to her
oh
she's she's wondering why we didn't
start it earlier
it was your fault say i told you so it
was your fault drew i'm sure i'm not
i don't know exactly how but i'm sure it
was your fault drew do not say i told
you so
that's that's never going to work right
all right good
good so um so we have college coming up
i have uh my three kids are 15
excuse me 17 15 and 14.
we have 27 000 left on the mortgage
um and uh based on uh
some advice you just gave jacob a little
while ago um
i think part of my answer uh question
was answered um
i i do have a non-retirement brokerage
account
that i had seventy seven thousand
dollars in
so i'm basically i was trying to figure
out what to do with that
should i pay off the 27 000 mortgage
should i open and fully fund
uh two roth retirement funds for my wife
and i
um what's your household income um
uh it's it's right at about 175.
excellent okay so here here's the here's
the uh
the hinge pin mathematically for your
whole situation
that'll set you guys free you need to
sit down and map out
for all three kids what you need what
they need for college
and how you're gonna do that and when
you see that number and you see how
you're gonna do
it it's gonna set you free to do the
other stuff
because here's what's happening if i'm
in your shoes you tell me if i'm wrong
but i think this is what
how i would be feeling if i was sitting
there i got this brokerage account i got
a 27 000
mortgage i could easily pay it off today
um and i need to get my iras funded but
god those kids that's coming at me like
a freight train right now
that that that big college bill is
looming and i don't know what it is
and i'm a little bit afraid if i pay
that mortgage off and i start my 15
baby step four into retirement that i'm
not going to have the money for college
right and i do you feel that way you
have uh
i do i do i i now i i do have
uh a 457 through work
good um that that i have uh 150
about 150 000 it all right so tell me
the ages of the kids again
uh 17 so uh she's a junior
um so we've got a little over a year and
a half um uh
15 these are freshmen and then 14.
so so i have that uh 457 also and
they uh my uh employer just changed the
management
of that 457 and as
for the past many years um they didn't
offer a roth
uh option and now they do so i've
stopped
putting into the regular i've opened up
the roth but it's
you know so i still have the okay here's
what i'm gonna do if i'm in your shoes
all right i'm just going to throw some
numbers down just for the fun of it but
i want you to go do a formal version of
this with your wife
okay let's let's say we research the
kids college
and a hundred thousand dollars will put
them through each
i don't think it will quite but i'm
going to use that number for a minute
okay so over the next four years
because i've got a 14 year old i need
300 grand
that makes sense yes i make 175
and so if i did four into 300 that'd be
75 a year
i can cash flow that
right yes you see how having the numbers
helps you relax a little bit
so i know seventy five thousand a year
for four years
and or a hundred thousand dollars a year
yeah for four years
you can cash flow that now a hundred
percent of the time i'm going to write a
check tonight
and pay off your mortgage knowing that i
can get there because you've already got
50 of your 300 to 400 that you're going
to need
77 minus 27 is 50 right yep right
okay i got 50 of it now the only
question is in order to cash flow it am
i going to have to tap the brakes a
little bit
on my retirement in order to cash flow
college because i got college right here
on top of me
of course the kids are gonna go to
school they're gonna they're gonna take
uh
act testing and they're gonna take it
again they're gonna apply for
scholarships we're going to affordable
schools we're not going to uber
expensive schools you don't have the
money
and you're going to go to you know
something you can afford but
even having done all of that you're
looking at a three to four hundred
thousand dollar bill
over this period of time yeah roughly
andrew once you do this
you've got your mortgage payment now
freed up because you paid off your house
yeah so the only question that remains
is
how much retirement am i going to be
able to do while i'm cash flowing
college for the next
four years actually right so there's one
uh wrinkle there too i i also will be
receiving a pension
um of probably right at about a hundred
thousand
when you retire or a lump sum yeah no
when i retire oh but we're not retiring
anything i'm saying way down the road
yeah because when the kids are through
school you're gonna load retirement
when the kids are when the kids are
through school you're gonna load up
retirement yeah
because you you've got that money so you
can do this you're going to be good
buddy
now what you have to do is stay allergic
to stupid from now
you got to map it out and you got to map
out the kids school yeah
and and have some firm discussions
starting tonight
on where you're going to school where
you're not 17 year old yeah i mean
this is this is real but i'm writing a
check paying off the house i got 50
started towards my three to four hundred
thousand dollar need
over the next four years before the last
one starts school
but we really have a total of eight
years to spread it across
so this makes it even more doable so you
can map out the actual cash needs
so the 17 year old starts i need this
much cash this year right so you got
your one out of your 50.
you probably got year two out of your
50. now the 15 year old starts school
and you got three and four for the first
one and you got the second one
right and you're going to end up with uh
two in school for quite a few years
at the same time but you can map that
cash out and
and out of your cash flow in your budget
again
with a reasonably priced education and
you're going to be able to do that and
then back into how much can i put
towards retirement
out of that and paying cash for school
so we're going to have the discussion
with them about that and we got
but if once you map this out it's going
to give you a ton of peace
just like when you started doing a
budget you felt like you got a raise but
all we're doing is we're mapping out the
next eight years which gets the 14 year
old four years starting school four
years to finish school yeah and now
you're not guessing you're not you don't
have this thing looming over your head
where you're wondering
you can sit down and actually know and
once you put a dollar amount to it now
you can put a savings plan toward it
yeah this will work this will absolutely
work hold on i'm gonna have kelly send
you a copy of debt free degree
number one bestseller by anthony o'neil
and you guys need to read that and the
kids need to read it
uh is it'll help you understand that you
can get a degree
debt-free especially when mom and dad
are 100
that free house and everything and make
175k
ding ding it's doable it's very doable
but we got to plan it out we got to
think about it and you can't you're not
going to
no one accidentally wins the super bowl
it doesn't happen
we noticed that the other night
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ecclesiastes 7
12 for the protection
of wisdom is like the protection of
money and the advantage of knowledge
is that wisdom preserves the life of him
who has it john zinger says
great leaders are not defined by the
absence of weakness but rather by the
presence of clear
strengths i've never heard that one that
is a good that's a good one that is a
good one
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host here today
david is with us in houston texas hi
david how are you
you know i don't know whether to say
better than i deserve or focus but not
finished
i'm doing pretty well that's a pretty
good hogan impersonation there that
david i'm gonna give you an a
on that one okay thanks
hey um i've got a question for y'all uh
i'm 30 years old
married i have uh two kids three and
under with one on the way
and i am blessed to be debt free except
for a mortgage
um we got about 125k left to pay off on
that
um kind of a back story is you know i
grew up kind of as an fbu kid my parents
did it back in 2006.
i read your book dave total money
makeover in 2008 and
we did fp as a couple in 2013.
but i'm kind of struggling now with
baby steps and burnout now we're on baby
steps four five and six
we purchased our home in 2015 as a
double income no kids
and then in 2017 uh my wife quit after
we had our daughter in the middle of
hurricane harvey
and uh took a big pay cut there to about
70k
then i was blessed out of promotion
before i i got a 42
pay raise in 2019 so now i'm making
about 110k
um so my question i guess is you know
with all the things that i found
the more money i make the more things
that they pay for whether that's 529 for
the kids
home insurance life insurance property
tax etc
so how can i keep my eyes and our eyes
on our financial goal
without running out of gas during dates
four five and six
well the first thing that comes to mind
is
baby steps one through three are gazelle
intensity
and four five and six are not you move
from
intensity intensity to intentionality
on for on four five and six so four five
and six
involves a budget for a vacation
it involves a budget for an upgrade in
vehicle it involves a budget for
you're running a marathon here you're
not running a sprint
and so you're not on beans and rice rice
and beans and you make 110 000 you've
done very well in your career
well done you're putting 15 percent of
your income away you don't have any
payments but a house payment you've got
an emergency fund in place
you have a very reasonable house
mortgage and you got some kids and
you're funding a 529
but you're you're slowing into a rhythm
run now you're not doing speed training
it's a marathon and i think you're still
have the trying to run the emotions at
least
if not maybe even trying to crank the
math down uh as if you were still
on gazelle intensity that'll burn you up
you can't do that yeah and david
you're also at that stage of life where
you've got all of these young kids
you got another one coming so you're
feeling the pressure and the strength
you're gonna get out yeah along with
them from home
along with lack of sleep are you working
from home too
yes sir oh yeah man so you let's let's
be honest
the mindset on the financial side is
they've said it's a mindset it's the
intentionality factor
but what you're feeling is the stress
and strain from the other things of
life and i want to tell you as a former
master isolator
because i was perfect at it i thought
you don't want to do life alone
and so you want to get some good guys
around you you want to have a connection
and a relationship to talk about
the stresses and strains of the kids of
the pressure
uh it's one of those things where we're
not meant to do life alone so you need
some community
yeah and
you know it's the stage you're in oh yes
i mean
you've got uh there's not a lot of
traction mathematically
with where you are in these baby steps
and
the kids just keep piling up here and
you're just like
i'm stuck and he doesn't get to leave
he's working from home
yeah yeah there's a lot that's a lot you
know
you're i think just saying all that out
loud
oh helps with the idea of burnout that
yes
a normal human being in your situation
would be stressed yes
so if you are stressed you are a normal
human you are normal
you are not a psychopath no and if you
were just
clueless then i would tell you i'd worry
about your mental health
you are feeling exactly where you are
right now in this season brother
we'll get you out of the house and
working yeah that'll be helpful it will
and we get the baby here the last one
that'll be that'll be gonna be the
the that'll be helpful yeah and you get
into you know but you're not going to
see
one of the frustrations that we've
watched people experience and i guess
we've all experienced that walk these
baby steps
is that you see such huge chunks of
traction in the first three
yeah and then when you go to four five
and six it just slows down
yes and it's the long haul this is a
it's a five seven year ten year slog
that's just a thought and we're just
that's why we budget in there for the
upgrades and some of the other things as
you go along you budget
right for this or that and um you know
if you need to back off on a 529 just a
little bit
in order to breathe have a fun
fund yes a little bit while you're here
this is the time that it's appropriate
to do that i just want you doing it on
purpose
and i don't want you to fall into debt
right because you take your
take your eyes completely off the ball
so you go from intensity to
intentional yeah and that's where we
want to be and david just like the
seasons of the weather this season too
will change my friend it really will
just hang in there with your wife
make sure you guys relationship is
connected get some
coaching if you need to or some
counseling if you need to
but get some good guys around you so you
can do life with them
because you got other fellows that are
feeling the same thing you know it's
weird it feels like it's yesterday in
some ways and in some ways it feels like
it was a hundred years ago but
the year rachel was born we filed
bankruptcy
we had no money that's why you filed
bankruptcy
and i got a toddler a marriage hanging
on by a thread i'm working from home
and i'm broke i got no money and
um you know sharon was to say the least
overwhelmed
she wanted me away she didn't want to
look at me to start with
that's pretty disgusted uh valid valid
but uh you know i mean we went through a
similar season
uh but much worse yeah in the sense of
there was not money for
uh the electric bill and there was not
money you know we're
i mean we didn't go hungry literally but
we were broke
we had no money and i had to go make
money every week in order to just pull
things together
and i got little babies my self-esteem
was destroyed
my marriage is on the rocks i mean it's
that was a tough
tough season and so it feels like when i
talk about it it comes up in my throat
and i remember it like it was yesterday
but it was you know
30 years ago so uh in that sense david
you're in a similar type thing but much
better and i'm not saying yours
is that your your feelings aren't valid
they are valid right
uh but you're just that that's what that
those young that young kid
stage of life they suck they suck the
marrow out of your bones yes
emotionally that's what they they're so
needy takers
we love them they're cute as they can be
but that's why when i have all the
grandbabies over i mean that's how i
send them back home
that's why i send them back home because
i love them but they need to go home
have to go home
you know and it's just they you know
when you're when you're six months old
and you can't do anything for yourself
you're
all you are is a taker man i mean we
love you you're cute as a button
and uh papa dave's gonna bounce you on
my knee but um
but they they do they pull the energy
out of and the math out of everything
and and so it is valid to feel that
it's not really a burnout it's more of a
i'm not getting traction yeah fatigue
it's a fatigue
it is a fatigue yeah it's a mental it's
a math fatigue an emotional fatigue a
spiritual fatigue
a relational fatigue yep and uh so yeah
just own that
and and say that that's real get some
guys guys of young families around you
like chris suggested
yeah form your group of guys get out of
the house yes
go to the store and just walk around go
in the backyard and hit a tree with a
stick
i don't know do something man i mean
that's get out of that house yeah let
your wife get out of the house too
take turns take turns yeah for god's
sakes yeah budget for a babysitter
that's a good thing
yeah i mean i'm with you brother that's
what we're saying but you'll get through
it and you can still hit your baby step
yes you can
just don't let this cause you to fall
off the horse that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you